in the eastern city of tobruk libya's
parliament selected a new prime minister
fete bashar was voted into office
unanimously he arrived in tripoli on
thursday night and was received by
hundreds of people
the former interior minister is widely
seen as western libya's strongman and
he's got the backing of powerful armed
groups across the country
including warlord khalifa hafters
self-proclaimed libyan national army or
lna which controls the oil-rich east
we welcome and support the decision of
the libyan parliament made on thursday
to appoint mr bashar as prime minister
and to form a government that leads to a
better future for all libyans
but interim prime minister abdul hamid
daba says he will not hand over power
i will not allow for new transitional
stages i will not be deterred from our
role in the government until elections
are held the government of national
unity will continue its work until it is
handed over to an elected government and
for the moment the un agrees
we've seen the reports of the
appointment of uh
of another uh prime minister this is
part of stephanie williams ongoing
consultations
our poli i mean our position that i
stated i think very clearly yesterday
remains unchanged if your position
remains unchanged you still recognize
the interim prime minister as the prime
minister of libya is that correct yes
the short answer is yes the baby's main
task as interim prime minister was to
hold elections but the country has two
rival legislatures the parliament in the
east and high council of state in the
west in december the vote was postponed
because they couldn't agree on the rules
for holding it
jabril's is a political analyst and says
changing the government now will only
prolong the conflict
parliamentary elections are the best
solution to the conflict because it ends
the mandate of the rival legislative
houses it's clear the parliament and
high council of state are blocking the
way and don't want elections in order to
stay in power
as a major political figure from libya's
west who has support from the main
warlord in the country's east feteh
bashar believes he can bring libya's
government back together but with the
u.n and other powers refusing to
recognize him as prime minister whether
he can bring stability to the country or
even take office both remain very
uncertain mala trainer al jazeera
tripoli